good morning thought I would just blog
my morning today for you guys and then
go edit it because and I'll have a video
for you today I haven't really been
vlogging because I feel like sometimes
when I vlog I do the same exact stuff
Hey look I'm making a snack Hey look I'm
taking the dog to get a haircut at some
point I get sick of editing it so you
guys have gotta get sick of watch like I
only want to do it with you guys we do
the same stuff every day but yet are you
bored yerba mate a dog food today I've
got a plan having a party this weekend
for Matt the human and we're having a
party here I also need to make a party
invite that's one of my most favorite
things is to make party invitations they
usually only get seen by like five
people but yeah my photoshop work I
never work harder I like to coordinate
my straws with the color of the cans
which yes it's mostly yellow but this is
the blue thoria yerba motivate guys like
squid yeah me and make my breakfast
not really filming today yeah that's
nice
he'll do that sometimes I'm filming but
then editing I've got some really boring
footage but I'm like how do I make this
entertaining
breakfast you know just do good boy he
knows he has to sit before I give him
his meal a little bit is nice let's see
what this looks like oh that looks
wonderful do we have a tech Tuesday in
here yes we do
I'll hide that one for later r2d2
measuring cups I ain't about that
majoring life but if I am this is how I
want to do it this is incredible
half cup holder cup one cup one kiss
one-fourth pissed dear boss this is
brilliant one-third Baptist are you
anything no how I put you back together
Oh [ __ ] holy moly
amazing this is just the coolest thing
I've ever seen what are you barking at
Oh something new you've never seen
before you've seen it but you were a
baby sit yeah yeah yeah yep oh wow you
like that such a big boy huh
here's the bad news
Rajaram that I move from the tables now
right in front of me well now this is
clean I guess I can go out of my video
okay
I'm gonna carry this and the tripod and
the foam is in my pants I don't think I
can go up the steps like this so far so
good like I know you guys do the same
thing it's so much easier to just make
two trips down the steps but the success
and satisfaction that you get when
carrying you know two loads of laundry
up the steps or this siculus contraption
I miss having a couch here
you love taking the lounge
there you go good boy you don't like the
couch I got a special for you
welcome to the command center why is
everything a mess I am I wish that I was
an organized person like I really try
but there's so many little tiny gadgets
and gizmos aplenty
and I suspect that I feel a little bit
better about my sort of organization now
he doesn't like his couch I did you
don't like it at time am I even in the
shot I love shooting with cameras that
are a really great quality but most of
the time they don't have a flip-out
screen so I can't see myself today am i
play some games my gaming channel today
but I'm not sure what to play I mean I
feel like moles from my free time this
past year has been spent playing with a
dog instead of playing video games I'm
not complaining about it but I miss
playing so much most of the stuff that
I've been playing recently is just
things that I can play on the go like
Pokemon Pokemon go get it maybe I would
have a Pokemon video today I don't know
the world is your oyster what does that
mean the world is my oyster or yours
this is it the world is one's oyster all
opportunities are over to someone the
world is theirs in order to achieve
something one has to grab the
opportunity you guys in the next video I
hope you guys have a great weekend I'm
gonna go play some games and play with
my doll you like sitting on Mommy's lap
now Oh
my handsome boy yeah see you guys later
have a good weekend bye to get the shot
cuz I'll bring all my items over here
three cups of white sugar coming up one